So I've been doing a little bit of kitchen supply shopping recently.
On one of my trips back home to England,
I stayed in this beautiful Airbnb in the English countryside.
It had one of those big old
traditional cast iron stoves and a cabinet full of Mason Cash bowls.
This took me right back to being a kid.
My aunt, my grandmother's,
they all had Mason Cash bowls in their kitchen when I was growing up,
and I miss them so badly.
Didn't wanna buy any while in England and bring them back
because I already got a bunch of other stuff that I was bringing back.
So I went searching online
and I found that Everything's Kitchen sells everything.
I love Mason Cash. My favourite bowl is this huge Mason Cash bowl.
This is the biggest one they sell,
and it's perfect for making sourdough bread.
I love to make my sourdough bread in batches.
So here I'm making three loaves.
I'm gonna make bake one straight away and put the rest in the fridge.
This is my absolute favorite way to make sourdough bread.
So I don't feel like I'm constantly making bread.
I just have one prep day,
and then we have three loaves throughout the week
for cooking for dinner. This is the perfect Christmas gift
for anyone who loves vintage kitchen items.